There are many different
distributions of Linux out there for
you to choose from.
So how do you make the right choice?
First, you need to understand
exactly what a distribution is and
the ways in which they can
differ from one another.
Because Linux is free as in speech,
people are free to make a variety of
choices when they decide to
create their own distribution.
They can choose what
software to include,
how that software should be updated, how
the community makes contributions, and
even how that particular distribution
can be shared with others.
For example, Red Hat Enterprise Linux is
a popular distribution for enterprises.
This particular distribution
is not free as in beer.
Companies have to pay a licensing fee.
In return for that payment, they have
the right to use the software and
receive support from Red Hat.
Ubuntu is another popular distribution
that itself has various versions.
Some tailored towards servers, others
for desktops, and even mobile phones.
Ubuntu receives consistent
updates to it's software,
which is how it differs from
it's parent distribution Debian.
Debian is known for
it's stability and reliability.
Many Debian servers have been up and
running for
years without requiring a reboot.
For this reason its software
updates cycle is very slow
when compared to others.